spire Cathedral is the world's largest
Romanesque Church that's still standing
the spire tax office is nearby it might
not be famous but it's vital for the
state of rheinland-pfalz it collects 800
million euros in annual tax revenue what
is the officials discuss the day's work
they've mailed out a whopping 120
reminders today the returns need to be
checked many taxpayers exploit any
loophole they can tax dodging isn't
really considered a serious crime the
computer alerts them when things don't
add up it's bad if someone is out sick
when older auditors retire there's no
one to replace them every auditor has to
get through a hundred cases each week
dessa vez de nada Bob this directive is
being applied to processing auditors
must stick to it because the next wave
to deal with is on its way downtown
kaisers lowchen is an hour away by car
just like in many other towns
construction sites abound as streets are
repaired in infrastructure modernized
that cost the federal government and
municipalities lots of money torsten
schlick of the german tax officials
union wonders why governments are
spending money on those projects while
imposing austerity at tax offices oh
playing and playing and we desperately
need more people our numbers show we
need fifteen thousand more to do our
jobs we lose about 30 billion euros
every year in value-added tax alone no
country in the world can afford that
could more tax auditors uncover more
cases of tax fraud inspire they say that
might not add up hi Standish that's
having more auditors doesn't necessarily
increase revenues hi to adam khan
deniska because of course there are
honest taxpayers too so we can't say
that more auditors definitely means more
taxes would be collected me up as an odd
side flash a yo-yo of computed
auditing honest returns takes about the
same amount of effort as uncovering
minor tax fraud and there are plenty of
upright taxpayers a key finance ministry
official visits regularly the idea is to
streamline the process to reduce
backlogs caused by lack of staff the
state government favors a completely
different approach taxpayers should
figure what they owe on their own in
Britain for example they've long been
approaching taxes this way rakuten we'd
like to give citizens more
responsibility and trust them or we'll
concentrate on cases that are
particularly difficult and complex and
will sample the other returns randomly
to ensure people aren't cheating logical
shonda special move in it all depends on
the auditors finding them is like
looking for a needle in a haystack they
have to study for three years at first
every change is exciting as a destroyer
vest is a feeling for tax law is very
diverse you always have to keep up with
it sets the soil there are always
revisions so you're always learning new
things and there's lots of variety fans
self pics from splash and they're
ambitious too they want to net the
really big tax dodgers it's a giant and
I of course that motivates but on the
foundation of fairness and equity the
primary aim is to ensure consistent
taxation does this thing just put me out
soon ultimately it's not about
maximizing tax revenues but being
certain that everyone pays precisely the
texteo